FEBRUARY NINETEENTH RULES
COMMITTEE MEETING TO ORDER AND
ASK MADAM SECRETARY TO CALL THE
ROLL SENATORS BATES HERE BATES
HERE MONNING MONNING HERE
ROUGH. ROUGH HERE WILK HERE
WILL CURE ATKINS HERE ATKINS
HERE JUST FOR YOU. THE ONE FOR
YOUR GAME. BUT YOU SORT OF DID
I'M USED TO HI OF WILL WELCOME
I AM GOING TO SEE IF WE CAN GET
A CONSENT AGENDA AND I WILL
MAKE. A SUGGESTION BECAUSE- WE
MIGHT NEED TO PULL ONE OUT
SEPARATELY SO ITEM NUMBER TWO
D. ITEM THREE REFERRAL OF BILLS
ITEM FOR RULE WAIVER REQUEST
ITEM FIVE THE RETARDED NEW IT'S
IN. ITEMS SIX. OUR THAT'S IT-
SO MOVED THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN CALLED. OKAY WHAT WE
PULL THAT. OKAY I WOULD YOU
WANT TO ASK IT AND OKAY. GO
AHEAD MADAM I WE JUST RECEIVED
THE OF A JUDGE THE INFORMATION
ON THIS AND THE QUESTION IS BOB
THE PERSON THAT'S WE HAVE
SELECTED TO DO THIS. WHO WAS
INVOLVED IN FROM WHERE WERE
THEY- YOU KNOW WE CREATED TO
REPLACE BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
SECURITY FOR OUR LEADERS NOT A
QUESTION BUT WHEN IT CAME SO
LATE AND I WILL SAY IN MY
DISTRICT THERE'S A LOT OF
ISSUES WERE GOOD REGARDING
DOUBLE DIPPING SO I NEED A
LITTLE MORE INFORMATION ON THE
SELECTION OF THIS PERSON AS A-
A NEW ATTENTION AND- THE
PROCESS FOR INTERVIEWING THEM
IN A VERY BRIEF JUST RIGHT ON
THE RECORD THING- VISIT- I WILL
I WILL DO MY BEST. ON THIS
PERSON RETIRED- MADAM SECRETARY
IN. SIX FEB. LET LET LET ME ASK
YOU BECAUSE WE DID THIS THROUGH
PERSONNEL AND THROUGH THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS BECAUSE IT IS
A SECURITY PERSONNEL- FOR SAN
DIEGO DUE TO- AN EXISTING AND
NEW IT'D HAVE BEEN BROKEN HER
FOOT- SO IT IS SORT OF A- PROS.
YOU KNOW IF AS TRACK BUT WAS I
INTERVIEWED BY THE SERGEANT AT
ARMS BY THE DISTRICT DIRECTOR
BY MYSELF AND THEN IF THE
CONCERN IS WHEN DID THE PERSON
RETIRE AND WHEN HOW LONG THAT
IT'S BEEN THE CASE. I WILL ASK-
MS CONTRAST TO RESPOND TO THAT
YES SO THE APPLICATION OF
RETIRED WITHIN THE LAST SIX
MONTHS. SO THE- THE OF THE
STATUTE REQUIRES WELL I
PROVIDES AN EXCEPTION FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICERS IN
SITUATIONS OF EMERGENCY- WE
DECIDED TO BRING IT TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE EVEN THOUGH
THERE WAS- STATUTORY AUTHORITY
TO BE ABLE TO BRING THEM ON
BOARD. WE DECIDED- TO GO
THROUGH THE NORMAL CHANNELS
BECAUSE THEY DID HAVE- ALL
RETIREMENT WITHIN THE LAST SIX
MONTHS- WHICH REQUIRES US TO
COME THROUGH THE RULES
COMMITTEE FOR ALL THEIR
EMPLOYEES EXCEPT FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY PERSONNEL. IN THIS CASE.
THE BECOMES AN EMPLOYEE OF THE
SENATE THEY WERE PREVIOUS CHP
EMPLOYEE- A RETIRED IN NEW IT
IT'D SO THEY WOULD. SELECT THE
WOULD BE BOUND TO THE SAME
RULES- UNDER PURRS AS A RETIRED
IN NEW ADDED FOR COMPENSATION
IN ANY KIND OF- OF OURS-
LIMITATIONS INFO COMING FROM C.
HPV OF THE QUALIFICATIONS OF
SECURITY AND ALL THAT. CORRECT
YES THE POST CERTIFIED YEAH
VERY GOOD THANK YOU. Q. IS A I
N. WHICH WAS ALSO THE REASON WE
WANTED TO GO THROUGH THE
REGULAR SYSTEM- BECAUSE IT WAS
OUT OF THE ORDINARY THAT WE
WOULD HAVE TO HIRE SOMEONE SO
QUICKLY. I JUST THINK THE
TIMELY NOW SEE IS IMPORTANT IN
TERMS OF RECEIVING SOMETHING
LINE AND IT CAME AT. SIX PM
LAST NIGHT AND I WASN'T THERE
SO. IT IS TO GET CLARIFICATION
THANK YOU. THEN I'M PREPARED TO
SUPPORT THAT ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA. THANK YOU SENATOR SO
AGAIN THAT IS ITEM TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR ITEM DE.
ITEM THREE BILL REFERRALS FOR
RULE WAIVER REQUEST FIVE THE
RETIRED ANNUITANT THANK YOU
MISS BATES. AND SIX THE FLOOR
KNOWLEDGE IT'S AN- MOTION WAS
MADE BY THE VICE CHAIRMAN. AND
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS BATES. BATES BY
MONNING. MONNING AYE ROSS. ROSS
SIDE WILK NINE WILK AYE ATKINS
SIGN A CONCISE. FIVE ZERO THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES I WILL GO AHEAD
AND TAKE ITEM TO E. R. ALSO AN
APPOINTMENT NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR. AT CAROLINE SIEGEL
SAYING- TO THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION- MOTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR OUR CALL THE
ROLL SENATORS BATES. BATES NO
MONNING MONNING AYE ROTH ROTH
AYE WILK ATKINS HI ATKINS I
THREE SO THAT'S THREE ONE I IT
IS CONFIRMED. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR WAITING I IT IS NOW WE WILL
MOVE ON TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIREDTO APPEAR-
MISTER PRESIDE OUT MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT BOARD WELCOME-
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO MAKE SOME
OPENING COMMENTS IF YOU WANT TO
INCLUDE SOME THANKS TO FAMILY
OR FRIENDS WHO MIGHT BE HERE.
AND THEN WE'LL GO RIGHT INTO
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS AFTER
YOUR BRIEF COMMENTS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU WILLIAM
PRESIDES- IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
HERE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE AND STAFF- IT'S
A TRUE HONOR. TO APPEAR BEFORE
YOU- ON MY CONFIRMATION TO THE-
BOARD OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM MY
BACKGROUND IS VERY GOOD-
EDUCATED TO BE A LAWYER I
PRACTICE LAW IN SAN FRANCISCO.
FOR OVER TEN YEARS SUBSEQUENTLY
RETURN TO MY NATIVE STATE WHICH
IS NEVADA. WHERE I ULTIMATELY
BEGAN TO ASSIST IN THE
MANAGEMENT OF TWO LARGE FAMILY
TRUSTS- I GAINED A BACKGROUND
IN FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT AND
SERVED ON NUMEROUS BOARDS OF
DIRECTORS FOR FINANCIALLY
RELATED ENTITIES. S WELL AS
PUBLICLY TRADED AND REGULATED
COMPANIES. HAVING BEEN
APPOINTED ALMOST A YEAR AGO
I'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE TO SERVE
FOR JUST OVER NINE MONTHS ON
THE BOARD I FOUND IT TO BE BOTH
CHALLENGING AND REWARDING. I'VE
LEARNED HOW SKILLED AND
TALENTED THE CAL STIRS STAFF
YEARS. AND I'VE SEEN HOW
COLLABORATIVELY THE BOARD WORKS
AS WELL. SIMPLY STATED. CAL
STARS IS A VALUE DRIVEN ORCHARD
CORD ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
UPHOLD ITS DUTIES TO ITS
MEMBERS AND TO PAY BENEFITS AS
THEY COME DUE. I STRONGLY
BELIEVE IN PUBLIC SERVICE WELL
OUR DEMOCRACY CONFERS FREEDOMS
IT ALSO COMES WITH
RESPONSIBILITIES DEMOCRACY IS A
PARTICIPATORY NOT A SPECTATOR
SPORT THE VALUES OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF PUBLIC EDUCATION
AND RESPECT FOR THOSE WHO
PROVIDED IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS
ARE CLEARLY REFLECTED IN THE
CARE IN SAFEGUARDING OF THE CAL
STIRS FUND. I COMMITTEE YOU I
WILL DO MY LEVEL BEST TO DO SO.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR MINING WANNA START
WITH YOU THIS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. MR PERCENT LET ME OFFER
MY CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU AND
OUR APPRECIATION FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO SHARE YOUR
EXPERTISE WITH. NOT ONLY THE
TEACHERS OF CALIFORNIA BUT WITH
ALL CALIFORNIANS WHO SUPPORT
SUPPORTER TEACHERS IN THEIR
EARNED RETIREMENT SADDAM WE HAD
A GOOD CONVERSATION I DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS BUT ONE
THAT. I THINK WOULD BE OF
INTEREST. TO OUR PANEL INTO
OTHERS. IN YOUR FIDUCIARY ROLE
WE HAVE INCREASING INTEREST IN
LOOKING AT INVESTMENT
PORTFOLIOS AND HOW THEY MIGHT
AFFECT OUR CLIMATE CRISIS- YOU
SHARED SOME OF YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THAT SOME OF THE HISTORIC
EVOLUTION. WOULD YOU MIND
SHARING SOME OF THAT WITH OUR
PANEL TODAY HAPPY TO SENATOR
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION- CAL
STIRS- I THINK HAS PROBABLY-
ONE OF THE LONGEST. HISTORIES
AS AN INSTITUTIONAL- INVESTOR
IN ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE
ISSUES- THEY'VE BEEN ENGAGING
WITH VARIOUS COMPANIES- THEY'VE
OF RECENTLY WE'VE ADOPTED A-
TRANSITION PLAN TO A FOSSIL
FREE ECONOMY- EACH OF THE ASSET
CLASSES THAT. ARE MANAGED
WITHIN THE PORTFOLIO OF NOW TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY PLUS BILLION
DOLLARS. AS AS AN ELEMENT OF
ANALYSIS FOR A DETERMINATION
WHETHER INVESTMENT HOULD BE
MADE OR NOT. IS A CONSIDERATION
OF. CLIMATE CHANGE AND ITS
IMPACT ON THE INVESTMENT.
BECAUSE WE'RE A LONG TERM
INVESTOR BEING AN INSTITUTIONAL
INVESTOR WE DON'T HAVE TO LOOK
AT THE NEW YEAR TERMS SO WE CAN
PROJECT OUT YOU KNOW WHAT
IMPACT A THE CLIMATE CHANGE
WILL HAVE ON INVESTMENTS BUT AS
A NEGATIVE IMPACT OVER TIME. IT
WILL BE A CONSIDERATION IN THE
DECISIONS MADE ON THAT
INVESTMENT. BUT I WANT TO
HASTEN TO ADD. THAT THE
OVERRIDING BY DO SHERRY UT. OF
MY FIGHT IS YOUR DUTY AS A AS A
MEMBER OF THE BOARD IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT BENEFITS ARE PAID TO
OUR MEMBERS IN A TIMELY WAY IN
SO THAT REALLY TAKES PRECEDENCE
YOU KNOW OUR FIGHT TO SHERRY
DUTIES MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
A FUNDED PLAN THEY CAN PAY.
BENEFITS WHEN THEY COME DUE.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE AND
ACTUALLY ONE OTHER QUESTION
RELATING TO OUR DISCUSSION. WE
PAY OUT TO FUND ADVISORS AND
CONSULTANTS I WAS SHOCKED TO
SEE ABOUT ONE POINT THREE
BILLION A YEAR I THINK YOU'VE
HAD SOME IDEAS IN THE BOARD
ABOUT BRINGING SOME MORE OF
THAT IN HOUSE COULD YOU JUST
SHARE. A LITTLE OF THAT
THINKING AND HAVE SOME OF THAT
MONEY MIGHT BE. BETTER
INVESTED. YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR FOR THE QUESTION.
WE FIRST START WITH THAT
BENEFITS PAID TO OUR MEMBERS
60% OF THOSE BENEFITS PLUS
SIXTY PLUS PERCENT OF THAT
COMES FROM INVESTMENT RETURNS.
THESE ARE NAPA RETURNS NET OF
FEES. WHILE 55% OF THE
PORTFOLIO. THAT'S BETTER ACCESS
TO TWO HUNDRED FIFTY BILLION
DOLLARS TODAY 55% OF IT IS
MANAGED IN HOUSE WHEN IT WAS
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
BILLION THAT FIFTY FIVE
PERCENT. COST US ABOUT THIRTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
APPROXIMATELY TO MANAGE THAT
WAS THE COST OF INTERNALLY
MANAGING. FOR THE OTHER 45%
WHICH WAS MANAGED BY OUTSIDE
MANAGERS IT WAS A BILLION EIGHT.
NOW HAVING BEEN A PERSON WHO
REALLY REVIEWED MANAGERS- WHEN
I WAS WORKING FOR THESE FAMILY
TRUST. I BEGAN TO SEE THE AT
FEES THAT WERE CHARGED YOU KNOW
THE TWO ONE TWENTIES THE 20%
BEING THE FEES THAT ARE CALLED
PROMOTES. THAT ADDS UP TO A LOT
OF MONEY. SO IF WE'RE PAYING
6270% OF THE BENEFITS TO OUR
MEMBERS. AND WE CANNOT PREDICT
WITH ANY CERTAINTY NO ONE CAN
WHAT KIND OF RETURNS WERE GONNA
GET WE CAN PREDICT OUR COSTS.
IN TO THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN
REDUCE OUR COSTS. THAT WILL BE
A BENEFIT TO OUR MEMBERS. AN
EVALUATION- WAS MADE- AND IT'S
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR WHICH IS
A CONSERVATIVE ESTIMATE THAT WE
SAVE BY INTERNALLY MANAGING. SO
THAT'S THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IT GOES INTO THE
POCKETS OF TEACHERS. SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE CAN INTERNALIZE
MORE MANAGEMENT OF OUR
PORTFOLIO. I THINK THAT THE
TEACHERS AND ULTIMATELY YOU
KNOW THE STATE ANOTHER YOU KNOW
CONTRIBUTORS TO THE PENSION
FUND. WILL BENEFIT SO I ARE I
STRONGLY ONE OF THE REASONS I
WANTED TO GO ON THIS BOARD WAS
TO ADVOCATE THAT POSITION I
THINK IT'S A VERY SMART
POSITION EVERY DOLLAR YOU
INVEST. TO HELP US INTERNALIZE
THE MANAGEMENT WILL RETURN YOU
MORE THAN TENFOLD. AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE CAN DO THAT I
THINK WE'RE- BEING WISE AND
PRUDENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS AND
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
CENTER BATES. THANK YOU WILL
LET ME ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE OF I THINK THAT THE
BOARD IS GOING TO BE WELL
SERVED. LOOKING AT YOUR
BACKGROUND MISTER RESIGNED CHEN
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU SAID IN YOUR
WRITTEN COMMENTS I DIDN'T TAKE
NO TIME WE DIDN'T HAVE A FACE
TO FACE. BUT OF OUR ONE OF THE
COMMENTS THAT YOU PROVIDED IN
YOUR WRITTEN RESPONSES THAT
CASTERS FUNDING PLAN REMAINS ON
TRACK. FOR FULL FUNDING BY
TWENTY FORTY SIX I THINK THERE
WERE SOME CONDITIONS TO THAT
COULD YOU JUST ELABORATE ON.
IT'S PRETTY HARD TO TELL THE
WHOLE PLAN TO GET IF THE TWENTY
FORTY SIX BUT WHAT IS THE MAYBE
THE MOST IMPORTANT COMPONENTS.
OF THAT CONTRACT TO GET IS
THERE BY TWENTY FORTY SIX
MILLION YOUR OB PROFESSIONAL-
OF JUDGMENT. WELL I THINK I'VE
ON ONE OF. LET YOU KNOW THAT I
DON'T HAVE A PER. JOB ABOUT.
THE PLAN I'VE ONLY BEEN THERE
FOR NINE MONTHS BUT I WILL TRY
TO GIVE YOU THE BEST ANSWER I
CAN. BEING RELATIVELY NEW. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT THE- THE- AB
I THINK WAS FOURTEEN SIXTY NINE
THAT WAS PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN. DID IT PROVIDED FOR
SOME FLEXIBILITY FORECASTERS TO
ALLOCATE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
PAYING INTO THE FUND. AND YOU
KNOW FROM FOR AGAIN FOR THE
EMPLOYER THE EMPLOYEE AND THE
STATE. AND SO THAT'S THAT 3240%
DO YOU KNOW THAT WE HAVE TO
MAKE UP THAT THAT THAT THE THAT
THE INVESTMENT RETURNS DON'T
PROVIDE. SO THAT IS DETERMINED
WHAT WE TRY TO DO IS THAT EVERY
FIVE YEARS THERE'S AN ASSET
LIABILITY MANAGEMENT PLAN THAT
IS ADOPTED. AND THIS IS WHERE
I'VE BEEN. I GOT AN EDUCATIONAL
KERR POINT ON THERE BUT- BUT
THE ACTUARIES DETERMINE WHAT
OUR OBLIGATIONS WILL BE OVER
TIME. AND THEN THEY WORK WITH
THE INVESTMENT TEAM TO
DETERMINE WHAT THE- RISK. A
COMPONENT WILL BE RISK RETURN
COMPONENT WILL BE AND SO THEN
WE DO AN ASSET ALLOCATION THAT
ASSET ALLOCATION ALSO PROVIDES
FOR A DETERMINATION OF WHAT ARE
PROJECTED RETURN WILL BE ARE
PROJECTED RETURN IS 7% NOW
PEOPLE SAYING THIS LOW RATE
ENVIRONMENT HOW CAN YOU DO THAT
WELL THIS IS LOOKED OUT OVER A
PERIOD OF TIME TEN YEARS. AND
IF HISTORY IS BROUGH THIS
ANYTHING HAS PROVEN ANYTHING IS
THAT THE LAST TEN YEARS WERE IN
DOUBLE DIGIT RETURNS YOU KNOW
OVER THE TEN YEARS. NOW THAT
WAS A GREAT MARKET. SO I GUESS
IS A LONG ANSWER BUT I I'M JUST
TRYING TO HELP. PUT IT IN
PERSPECTIVE IS THAT. BASED ON
THAT WE CAN DETERMINE THE
IMPACT. THAT IT WILL HAVE ON
THE CONTRIBUTORS TO THE PLAN.
AND THAT'S IT BECAUSE WE HAVE
TO PROJECT OUT WHAT OUR RETURNS
WILL BE. SO THAT'S HOW WE
DETERMINE HOW WE KEEP IN ON
TRACK TO GET TO NINETEEN FORTY
SIX. IT'S WITH ACTUARIES AND
INVESTMENT TEAM WORKING
TOGETHER ONE OF THE THING I'D
LIKE TO ADD. BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO
UNDERSTAND- AND MAYBE YOU DO
BUT- I DIDN'T. AND THAT IS
REALLY HOW COLLABORATIVELY. THE
TEAM WORKS. AT CAL STARS. I
MEAN IT IS IT IS REALLY TRULY
REFRESHING BECAUSE I YOU KNOW
WATCHING ASSET MANAGERS IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR. EVERY PORTFOLIO
MANAGER THINKS HE OR SHE IS THE
SMARTEST PERSON IN THE ROOM.
BUT THERE IS THIS GREAT
COLLABORATION AMONG- THEM THE
PEOPLE THAT WORK AT CAL STIRS.
AND I THINK IT'S A TESTIMONY TO
THE LEADERSHIP THEY'RE- BOTH IN
THE INVESTMENT SIDE IN ON THE
ADMINISTRATIVE SIDE. IT'S BEEN
TERRIFIC BECAUSE I I'VE SEEN
LOTS OF INSTITUTIONS AND YOU
KNOW COMPANIES THAT DON'T HAVE
THIS VALUE DRIVEN LEADERSHIP. I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I KNOW WAS
KIND OF CALM. BUT HAVING SERVED
ON ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS AND HEARING ABOUT THE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY IN THE
PROJECTIONS YOU JUST SHARED
WITH ME ESSENTIALLY. ARE KINDA
REMINDED ME I GUESS OF ALL OF
THE DIFFERENT MOVING PARTS IN
IT IS BASED ON PROJECTION AND
PAST HISTORY. IN THE ON YOU
KNOW OUR BALANCING THOSE TWO ON
THE CONTINUE ON. SO THANK YOU
LIKE I SAID- I THINK YOU BRING
A GREAT PERSPECTIVE FROM THE
OUTSIDE THE AND IN TALKING
ABOUT THE COLLABORATION THAT
GOES ON THERE. THAT SUBSTANTIAL
ESSENTIAL TO I THINK
DETERMINING RISK AND
DETERMINING WHAT THE
INVESTMENTS NEED TO BE SO. YOU
WILL HAVE MY FULL SUPPORT- FOR
YEAR- CONFIRMATION AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR STEPPING UP
TO TAKE THAT. YEAH THANK YOU
VICE CHAIR. THANK YOU MAYOR PRO
TEM I JUST WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES I
ACTUALLY ENJOYED OUR
CONVERSATION AND LEARN- QUITE A
BIT- IN TERMS OF AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY NINE EVERYBODY AT THIS
DíAS VOTED FOR IT SO IF YOU
DON'T LIKE A YOU TO COME BACK
TO US AT A LATER DATE NOT TELL
US THAT TELLS OUT IT TELLS HOW
TO FIX IT- OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT WERE ASKED WERE THE ONES I
WAS GONNA ASK- AGAIN I'M VERY
COMFORTABLE. THE ONE THING THAT
REALLY SHOW THROUGH WITH ME
TODAY IS THAT I THINK OUR
GREATEST PUBLIC SERVANTS OUR
OUR TEACHERS AND YOUR PASSION
IN MAKING SURE THAT WE DELIVER
WHAT WE PROMISED REALLY KIND OF
SHOWN THROUGH TODAY WHICH I
APPRECIATE LOOKING FOR DAY
ANYTHING I CAN DO TO HELP YOU
LET ME KNOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH
RELATIONS THANK YOU. KEY CENTER.
THANK YOU MAY PRO TEM UM. YOU
KNOW I THINK WE ALL WANT TO
LOOK. IN TO. SERVICES AND
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO
REALLY- I WAS JUST CURIOUS WHAT
THE RATIONALE. WAS OR IS FOR
THE- OUTSIDE VERSUS INSIDE
ASSET MANAGEMENT SPLIT THAT YOU
REFERRED 255405% AND WHAT AND
WHETHER RISK MANAGEMENT- ASSET
DIVERSIFICATION PLAYS ANY ROLE
PLAYED ANY ROLE IN THAT
DETERMINATION. JENNIFER
QUESTION OR TWO GAS AND YET
THEY'RE THEY'RE PROBABLY- I'LL
BREAK IT DOWN INTO TWO PARTS IF
I MAY. THE FIRST PART IS WHEN
YOU HAVE A PORTFOLIO- AS LARGE
AS THIS OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE TO- SPREAD YOUR RISK. IN
THE PORTFOLIO MANAGEMENT YOU
KNOW IS DIFFERENT BUCKETS OF
ASSETS THAT YOU TO INVEST IN SO
THAT IF FOR EXAMPLE EQUITIES
ARE IN THE TANK MAY BE FIXED
INCOME AND INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS ARE DOING WELL YOU
KNOW OR OR AT LEAST HOLDING
THEIR OWN. SO THAT IS WHY YOU
HAVE YOU KNOW THE DIVERSITY OF
INVESTMENTS IS TO PROTECT
YOURSELF AGAINST- RISK- WITH
REGARD TO ASSETS BEING MANAGED
INTERNALLY AS OPPOSED TO
EXTERNALLY THE KISS STORY PLEA-
CAL STIRS AS I UNDERSTAND IT-
WAS ALL EXTERNALLY MANAGEMENT I
THINK MANY PENSION FUNDS HERE
IN THE STATES WERE ALL
EXTERNALLY MANAGE FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME. I THINK THAT
THAT WHAT HAPPENED WAS THAT-
THERE WAS A RECOGNITION. THAT
OTHER LARGE INSTITUTIONAL
INVESTORS WERE. GETTING BETTER
RETURNS NET RETURNS BY BRINGING
THOSE MANAGEMENT SERVICES IN
HOUSE. AND I THINK PROBABLY THE
GROWTH OF INDEXED EQUITY
INVESTING WHICH MAKES IT A
LITTLE BIT EASIER YOU DON'T
HAVE STOCK PICKERS YOU HAVE YOU
KNOW INDEX FUNDS THAT YOU
INVESTED. I THINK THAT PROBABLY
ASSISTED IN IN IN MOVING IT UP
MORE QUICKLY. THE THERE'S IN
CANADA FOR EXAMPLE THERE ARE
MANY PENSION FUNDS WHICH IN
BASICALLY HAVE ALL OF THE
MANAGEMENT OF THE FUNDS AN
INTERNAL. AND I THINK THAT THAT
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS- THAT WE
ULTIMATELY FACE IN DOING THAT-
HERE IN IN IN IN THE STATE'S IN
CALIFORNIA. IS THAT WORSE WE
HAVE- AN INVESTMENT MANAGEMENT
AND. AND PENSION BENEFITS
COMPANY TO TWO DIFFERENT KINDS
OF COMPANIS AND CAL STAR SO
YOU KNOW WE MANAGE IT WE
INVESTMENT MANAGE AND WE ALSO
PAY PENSION BENEFITS SO WE'VE
GOT REALLY PRIVATE KINDS OF
BUSINESSES WE RUN BUT SUBJECT
TO A LOT OF THE STATE
REGULATORY YOU KNOW EMPLOYMENT-
YOU KNOW BURKE LOS. AND SO TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN WE'VE
BEEN MOVING- TOWARD.
INTERNALIZING AS MUCH AS WE CAN
AND SO I HONESTLY BELIEVE THAT
AS TIME GOES ON. YOU KNOW WE
WERE GONNA PROBABLY NEED TO
HAVE- MORE FREEDOM IN HIRING
PEOPLE THAT WILL NOT BE SUBJECT
TO THE CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW THE
CIVIL SERVICE REQUIREMENTS NOW
I SAY THAT. NOT KNOWING ENOUGH
REALLY BUT I KNOW THAT IT TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE WANT TO
MANAGE INTERNALLY A LOT OF
ASSETS- WE'RE GONNA NEED YOU
KNOW OF A WE NEED TO HIRE GOOD
PEOPLE AND GOOD PEOPLE ON THE
OUTSIDE. MAKE A LOT MORE MONEY
AND THAT'S GOING TO BE A
CHALLENGE. I WAS GOING TO ASK
IF THERE WERE STATUTORY OR
REGULATORY IMPEDIMENTS TO
MOVING. AWAY FROM THE FIFTY
FIVE FORTY FIVE SPLIT IN TERMS
OF OUTSIDE VERSUS INSIDE
INVESTMENT MANAGEMENT AND IF SO
WHAT THOSE ARE I SUPPOSE WE
COULD SAY THAT FOR ANOTHER DAY
AND ANOTHER CONVERSATION WELL
AND- AND HOPEFULLY SOMEBODY
THAT'S BETTER INFORMED AND I
BECAUSE- AT THIS POINT IN TIME
I DON'T KNOW ENOUGH TO ENGAGE
IN THAT CONVERSATION BUT I CAN
TELL YOU THAT I IN ANYTHING YOU
CAN. HELP DO THAT. I THINK THAT
IS WELL INVESTED MONEY. WELL I
WILL SAY THAT YOU'RE NOT ALONE
I MEAN AS I RECALL WE HAVE THE
SAME. WHENEVER THE STATE-
ENGAGES IN OPERATIONS CENTER.
OF EXACTLY THE SAME REQUIRED
SIMILAR TO THOSE OF THE
COMMERCIAL SIDE ENGAGES AND WE
HAVE A PROBLEM AND- WE HAVE THE
SAME SITUATION OR SOMETHING
SIMILAR IN THE INSURANCE.
BUSINESS WHEN WHERE WITH THE
STATE FUND AND OUR WORKERS ARE
ARE FORAY INTO THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION FIELD AS WELL IN
TERMS OF. PAYING PEOPLE ENOUGH
MONEY TO COME IN AND HELP US
MANAGE AN OPERATION THAT WOULD
GARNER MUCH MORE. MONEY IN THE
OUTSIDE IN THE COMMERCIAL-
COMMERCIAL SIDE OF THINGS SO
LOOK FORWARD TO TALKING WITH
YOU- CONGRATULATIONS AFFORD TO
SUPPORTING AND MOVING YOUR CUT-
A CONFIRMATION OF THE PERFECT
POINT AFTER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR I APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU SENATOR I JUST HAVE
ONE AREA AND- I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSES ON A
NUMBER OF THESE ISSUES
PARTICULARLY THE COST SIDE. OF
BECAUSE FOR SO MANY OF US- IT
IS NOT THE WORLD WE LIVE IN BUT
WE GET HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
SYSTEMS AND IT'S CERTAINLY.
FRONT CENTER OF EVERYONE'S MIND
SO PARTICULARLY THE COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS ARE RELATED TO
OPERATIONS AND COST AND HOW TO
SAVE MONEY I APPRECIATE. LAST
JUNE CAL STIRS IN CALPERS
PARTNER TO HOSTED DIVERSITY
FORUM. AND OF COURSE AREAS
INCLUDED THINGS LIKE WOMEN AND
MINORITIES IN CORPORATE BOARDS
INVESTMENT MANAGEMENT FIRMS
EXAMINING UNCONSCIOUS BIAS- OF
A SEX INCLUSION. BEST PRACTICES
FOR INCLUSIVE CULTURES WHAT I
WOULD ASK IS WHAT ARE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAYS TO BUILD AN
INCLUSIVE CULTURE. IN THE
INVESTMENT WORLD I MEAN WE
OBVIOUSLY HAVE LEGISLATED
THINGS BUT I'M JUST CURIOUS
FROM YOUR HISTORY EXPERIENCE.
HOW DO YOU RECOMMEND ADDRESS
AND ISSUES LIKE THAT WITH IN
AND INVESTMENT SYSTEM. WELL
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION THANK
YOU SENATOR- I THINK THAT ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT IF YOU'RE
GOING TO- ASK SOMEONE TO DO
SOMETHING IF YOU HAVEN'T DONE
IT YOURSELF. IT'S PRETTY HARD
TO MAKE THAT ASK AND I CAN TELL
YOU WITH ABSOLUTE CERTAINTY
BECAUSE I'M I'M THERE ARE AT
CAL STIRS. THAT A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF OUR PORTFOLIO
MANAGERS ARE WOMEN. AND SO- CAL
STIRS NOT ONLY TALKS THE TALK
THROUGH ENGAGEMENT WITH THESE
COMPANIES IT WALKS THE WALK.
AND SO I THINK YOU SEVEN
EXAMPLE WHEN YOU WHEN YOU'RE A
LARGE INSTITUTIONAL INVESTOR.
AND YOU CAN POINT TO YOUR
ARE MANY WOMEN THERE THE WOMAN
WHO THE GLOBAL EQUITY SWITCHES
FORTY SOME ODD PERCENT OF THE
TOTAL PORTFOLIO. IF PORTFOLIO
MANAGER THAT THAT ASSET CLASS
IS A WOMAN. PRIVATE EQUITIES A
WOMAN SO- THAT'S NUMBER ONE YOU
HAVE TO LEAD BY EXAMPLE TWO I
KNOW THAT WE ENGAGE FOR WE MAKE
ANY DETERMINATION. WITH A
MANAGER TO DETERMINE THAT AND I
KNOW THAT IT IS JUST BECAUSE OF
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE OF
CASTERS IT'S IN VERY VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. BUT AGAIN I
THINK YOU START WITH LEAD BY
EXAMPLE ENGAGE SO THAT YOU HAVE
CREDIBILITY WHEN YOU ENGAGE YOU
CAN TURN AROUND AT THE FOR THE
PERSON YOU'RE TALKING TO AND
SAY WE'D BE HAPPY TO INVEST
WITH YOU BOUGHT. YOU KNOW YOU
DON'T HAVE WHAT WE NEED WHICH
IS MORE DIVERSITY. SO ANYWAY I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT ANSWERS THE
QUESTION IT DOES LOUIS IT LET
ME ASK- OBVIOUSLY IT'S
INTENTIONAL. I AM IN DIVERSITY
DOESN'T JUST HAPPEN IN ANY WAY
SHAPE OR FORM IT'S INTENTIONAL
WHETHER WE'RE TALKIN REGIONAL
DIVERSITY INVESTMENT THERE ARE
ALL KINDS OF DIVERSITY. BUT I
IT'S INTENTIONAL. IT IS I DID
DID DO YOU FIND THAT OF SOME
OTHER FEEDBACK I'VE GOTTEN IS
YOU WILL NOT GET THE QUALITY OF
SERVICE THAT YOU NEED AND SO I
JUST WANT TO ON THE RECORD HERE
YOU SAY HOPEFULLY THAT YOU OR
YOUR BORDERS ABLE TO FIND THE
QUALITY YOU NEED AND MEET THOSE
INTENTIONAL KIND OF GOALS FOR
THE SYSTEM I BELIEVE THAT TO BE
TRUE BUT I CAN ONLY SPEAK FOR
MY OWN EXPERIENCE SO YOU HAVE
GOOD EXPERIENCE FROM THE RESUME
THAT I'M LOOKING AT. FROM MY
OWN EXPERIENCE- I CHAIRED IN
NEW YORK STOCK EXCHANGE BOARD-
POSITION WHERE I RAN THE
GOVERNANCE COMMITTEE WHEN I
CAME ON THAT BOARD THERE WERE
NO WOMEN ON THE BOARD THAT
WASN'T THE LARGEST COMPANY WAS
IT THERE WAS A READ INVESTED IN
HOTELS OWNED HOTELS. AND I SAID
YOU KNOW WE REALLY DO NEED TO
YOU KNOW HAVE. YOU MORE
DIVERSITY ON THIS BOARD AND-
WHICH SUBSEQUENTLY WE- WE GOT A
WOMAN ON THE BOARD WHO TURNED
OUT TO BE END UP BEING THE VICE
CHAIR OF THE BOARD WHO IS-PROBABLY THE MOST- AFFECTED
BOARD MEMBER THAT I WORKED WITH
SHE AND SO I THINK THAT. FROM
MY OWN EXPERIENCE I SEE IT AS A
NO BRAINER I MEAN YOU JUST YOU
YOU KNOW YOU FIND TALENT AND IN
THIS DAY AND AGE AND I THINK
BECAUSE OF. YOU KNOW THIS
BATTLE HAS BEEN. FOR WOMEN IS
BEING HAS BEEN FOUGHT FOR A
LONG TIME NOW. AND I THINK THE
BENEFITS OF THIS YOU KNOW
YOU'RE SEEING IT IN THE WORK
FORCE THROUGHOUT THE WORK FORCE
TODAY. I THINK YOU SEE MORE AND
MORE TALENTED. WELL EDUCATED
EXPERIENCE WOMEN. THAT YOU CAN
DRAW FROM. AND TO ME I WOULD.
YOU KNOW MY EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN.
I LIKE WORKING ON BOARDS THAT
ARE COLLABORATIVE MY EXPERIENCE
HAS BEEN THAT THERE IS MORE
COLLABORATION WITH A WOMAN
BOARD MEMBER THEN OFTENTIMES
WITH SOME MEN BACK MORTARBOARD
MEMBERS THEY'RE MUCH MORE
WILLING TO COLLABORATE- AND I-THINK YOU'RE MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVE. WHEN YOU HAVE A
BOARD THAT'S WILLING TO WORK
TOGETHER AND NOT SACRIFICE THE
SUCCESS OF THE GOALS THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH IS
THAT FINANCIALLY. EXACTLY I
APPRECIATE THAT I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS- IF NOTHING ELSE
I WILL GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. LET ME CALL UP
FIRST THOSE THAT MIGHT BE HERE
IN SUPPORT- WE HAVE A MIKE ANA.
THAT THAT COULD BE VERY GOOD
SIGN- BOB BYE SO MY NEXT
QUESTION IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN OPPOSITION. OBVIOUSLY IT'S A
GOOD SIGN. THANK YOU SENATOR
ROTH HAS MOVED YOUR
CONFIRMATION MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATORS
BATES BATES AYE MONNING MONNING
AYE ROSS ROSS I WILL WILK AYE
ATKINS HI A CONCISE
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE. LET ME SEE I'D CALL
MR BROUGHT FORWARD MEMBER OF
THE AGRICULTURAL LABOR
RELATIONS BOARD WELCOME. THANK
YOU. LET ME INVITE YOU TO OF
COURSE OPENING COMMENTS THANK
ANYONE YOU WOULD LIKE THIS WITH
YOU AND THEN WE'LL GO RIGHT
INTO IT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- WELL LET ME
INTRODUCE MY FAMILY THAT'S HERE.
MY MOM TV RASCON. WELCOME MY
SON MATTY BROAD OR MATT PRIDE
AS YOU KNOW HIM. BY AND MY WIFE
IT'S OBVIOUSLY A HUGE PRIVILEGE
FOR ME TO BE HERE TO HAVE BEEN
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR TO
THIS POSITION IT'S SOMETHING OF
A DREAM COME TRUE FOR ME THIS
JOB- AND- AND- IT'S INCREDIBLY
ENJOYABLE IT IT'S A HUGE
PRIVILEGE TO ENGAGE IN THIS
PUBLIC SERVICE I JUST HAVE A
COUPLE OF PRELIMINARY POINTS
THAT I'D LIKE TO MAKE ABOUT
THINGS THAT I'D LIKE TO
ACCOMPLISH WHILE LINE ON THIS
BOARD. I OF. I WOULD LIKE TO
HELP EXPAND ARE OUT OF REACH IN
THE- COMMUNITY THAT WE SERVE
NOT ONLY A FARMWORKERS BY. THE
GROWERS AS WELL ON WE DO A GOOD
JOB DOING IT WITH THE RESOURCES
THAT WE HAVE WE HAVE A SMALL
AGENCY THERE'S ONLY SIXTY
EMPLOYEES AND WE DO IT AS BEST
WE CAN AND I THINK WE DO A GOOD
JOB. I THINK THE BOARD ITSELF
ESPECIALLY IF WE GET. NEW
APPOINTEES OR MORE APPOINTEE'S
I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
PARTICIPATE. IN THAT PROCESS AS
WELL. ON MEETING WITH LABOR
MEETING WITH BUSINESS MEETING
WITH COMMUNITY GROUPS. ON COULD
TO HELP- EDUCATE THE PUBLIC.
OUR STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT WHAT WE
DO AND JUST SORT OF WHO WE ARE
WHICH KIND OF LEADS TO MY
SECOND POINT- IN A MORE
CHALLENGING THING. I THIS
BOARD- IS A BOARD IN WHICH OF
BOTH THE LABOR SIDE IN THE
MANAGEMENT SIDE AND I'VE MET
WITH BLOW OFF. ARE DISSATISFIED.
ON MUCH OF THE TIME AND
FRUSTRATED AND- YOU KNOW IT'S
SORT OF AN OLD WE SAY IT ALL
THE TIME WELL EVERYBODY'S ON
HAPPY YOU MUST BE DOING
SOMETHING RIGHT BUT THE FACT OF
THE MATTER IS IF EVERYBODY'S ON
HAPPY PROBABLY THINGS CAN BE
IMPROVED NOW YOU CAN'T IMPROVE
THE FACT THAT THIS IS AN
ADVERSARIAL- UP A BOARD THAT
DEALS WITH RESOLVING. ISSUES
BETWEEN ADVERSARIES IT IS NOT
YOU KNOW- BUT THAT KIND OF A
FEEL GOOD INSTITUTION IT'S LIKE
A COURT IT IS A COURT AND EIGHT
ADJUDICATES CLAIMS SO WE CAN'T
SUGARCOAT THAT. WHAT ON FROM
THE PERSPECTIVE OF LABOR THESE
CASES ARE LITIGATED IN
LITIGATED IN LITIGATED FOR EVER
WHICH SORT OF UNDERMINES THINGS
EVEN IF YOU WIN AND FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE EMPLOYERS
THEY FEEL FRANKLY THAT THEY
NEVER WITH. AND SOMEWHERE IN
BETWEEN ALL THAT LIES THE TRUTH
BUT WHAT WE CAN DO. IS TO TRY
TO WORK REALLY HARD AND THIS
GOS BACK TO MY FIRST POINT
ABOUT. BEING OUT THERE WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE THEM FEEL
SOME CONFIDENCE THAT WHETHER
THEY WIN OR LOSE AND NOBODY'S
ENTITLED TO WIN AND YOU KNOW
EVERY TIME OR LOSE EVERY TIME
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT- BUT TO
THE EXTENT THAT THEY NGUYEN IN
THEY LOSE. THEY WENT IN THEY
LOSE BECAUSE THE PROCESS WAS
FAIR AND IMPARTIAL. AND THAT
THEY HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT
THEY'RE BEING HEARD AND NOT
BEING DISMISSED AND THAT'S A
TALL ORDER- BUT I'D LIKE TO USE
MY TIME ON THIS BOARD TO TRY TO
MOVE THAT NOTION FORWARD. SO
THAT THIS BOARD BECOMES A
LITTLE LESS OF AN AREA IN WHICH
ON ALL SIDES FEEL AGGRIEVED AND
MAYBE ALL SIDES FEEL MOVED
TOWARDS YEAH YOU KNOW I DON'T
ALWAYS WIN BUT YOU KNOW WHAT
IT'S FAIR. SO WITH THAT I AM
PREPARED TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU CENTER
ROTH A MAN PRO TEM- ACTUALLY. I
DON'T REALLY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
FIRST I WANT TO CONGRATULATE
YOU SIR FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
STEP UP AND SERVE IT HASN'T
BEEN THAT MANY YEARS AGO- SINCE
I'VE BEEN UP HERE WHEN WE HAD A
HEARING IN A DIFFERENT SETTING
ON A DIFFERENT ISSUE. HAVING TO
DO WITH THE AGRICULTURAL LABOR
RELATIONS BOARD WHERE. YOU KNOW
I CAME OUT OF THE NATIONAL
LABOR RELATIONS BOARD NOT TOO
LONG AFTER THIS ONE WAS-CREATED. AND I HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS OF THE BOARD
REPRESENTATIVE IN FRONT OF ME
HAVING TO DO WITH THE- AVERAGE
CASELOAD PER ATTORNEY AND-
FIELD EXAMINER FIELD AGENTS AND
THE RESPONSE I GOT WAS I DON'T
KNOW. WHICH WAS NOT TOTALLY
SATISFACTORY TO ME SO. I'M SURE
THINGS HAVE CHANGED SINCE THE
DATE AND I CERTAINLY LOOK
FORWARD TO OF. YOUR SERVICE ON
THE BOARD- THE INJECTION OF NEW
AND SUSIE AS A MAN VISION. AND
MISSION FOR THE BOARD AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU ON THE
SUBJECTS SO. WITH THAT AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS MAN APPROACHED
HIM I LOOK FORWARD TO WIN
MAKING THE MOTION TO CONFIRM AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU
MAYOR PRO TEM I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS EITHER OBVIOUSLY HERE
LONG STAND STANDING CAPITAL
FIGURE WITH AN EXCELLENT
REPUTATION LITTLE DISAPPOINTED
YOU DIDN'T BRING YOUR DOGS AS A
DOG PERSON SHOULD DO WHATEVER
IT TAKES TO GET IT HOW MANY FOR
VOTE YOU CAN GET BUT- WITH THAT
WANT TO CONGRATULATE YOU AND
I'M SURE YOU'RE GOING TO BE A
VIBRANT VOICE ON THAT BOARD.
THANK YOU. YOU WANT TO RESPOND
TO NOT BRING IN YOUR DOGS. I AM
HAPPY TO MEET YOU AT ANY TIME
AND- DEAL WITH THE DOG ISSUES
YES. WHEN I BRING MY DOG YES
WHAT WILL START A DOG WILL
START A DOG PARK. THERE YOU GO
I'M ALL IN FAVOR SENATOR BATES.
WELL THANK YOU MISTER RODHAM IN
A CAR YOU BURY FLY LINE DO A
VERY LONG LONG TIME- FOR SO
THANK YOU THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE
RESUME OF SERVICE- IN IN THE-
WORK OF THE PUBLIC SO OF
REMARKABLE IN TERMS OF THE
YEARS THAT YOU'VE SERVED- I
STILL NEED TO DO SOME OUT
REACHING MY DISTRICT ON ON THE
QUESTIONS SO I WILL BE OF
STAINING TODAY BUT IT IS NOT TO
BE TAKEN AS SOMETHING THAT.
DOESN'T REALLY SALUTE YOU AND I
KNOW THAT YOU ARE WILL BE A
GREAT SERVICE TO THIS BOARD I
THINK IT MIGHT BE IMPORTANT
JUST FOR THE GENERAL
CONVERSATION TO- I ASKED THE
QUESTION ARE SINCE. THE OF
COMPLAINTS THAT COME TO YOU
REALLY YOU SERVE AS AN APPEALS
BOARD ESSENTIALLY BECAUSE IT'S
ALREADY BEEN OFFICIALLY
ESTABLISHED I THINK YOU USE THE
TERM OR THE AMOUNT NINETY SEVEN
PERCENT. AND THE QUESTION I
ASKED AND DO WE REALLY NEED THE
BOARD AND YOU MADE IT VERY
CLEAR WHY THE LITTLE IN THIS
MORNING SO IMPORTANT IN THAT
PROCESS AND IF YOU'D SHARE THAT
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THAT FOR.
YOU VERY IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE
TO UNDERSTAND THAT OUT TO YOU
THE ROLE IN THE DEFLATE THE
PROPER COULD PROCESS TORIO.
BOARDS ARE THAT HAS THAT
AUTHORITY RIGHT WAS SOMETHING I
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND ANY RIGHT ONE
NIGHT I WANT I WAS MAKING WITH
THE WHICH I'M I'M HAPPY TO
SHARE. IS THAT BECAUSE WE ARE A
PROSECUTORIAL BOARD THAT OUR
GENERAL COUNSEL MAKES A
DECISION ABOUT WHETHER THEY'RE
SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE CHARGE. WHICH
IS CONTRASTED WITH AND ONE
PROSECUTORIAL BOARD WHITE THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS
BOARD IS AN EXAMPLE. ANY PARTY
COULD BRING A CHARGE THE CHARGE
MOVES FORWARD OF THAT. WANT TO
MOVE IT FORWARD. THERE THERE.
CURRENT NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE THEIR CASE FOR BUT THE
ESSENTIAL SOMEONE WHO BRINGS. A
CHARGES LIKE SOMEONE BRING FOR
INFORMATION TO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY THE DISH TURN MAKES IT
IS WHERE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE K. SO THAT EVERY TIME THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY MAKES A
DECISION OR IN OUR CASE THE
GENERAL COUNSEL MAKES A
DECISION WHETHER ISN'T
SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE TO MOVE
FORWARD I DON'T THINK THIS IS A
STRONG ENOUGH CASE AND I'M NOT
GOING TO MOVE THE PROCESS
FORWARD THAT IS SORT OF A WIN
FOR THE EMPLOYER IF THE
EMPLOYER IS THE ENTITY CHARGED-
FOR WOULD BE CHARGED. SO WE
DON'T THAT DOESN'T SHOW UP IN
STATISTICS IF YOU WELL SO A LOT
OF WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT AS THE
PROCESS MOVES FORWARD IT MOVES
FORWARD MOSTLY- AGAINST
EMPLOYERS THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE GENERALLY CHARGED ON
IN ALL OF THESE LABOR LAW
SYSTEMS AND THE IT'S HEARD BY-
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE AND
THEREFORE MOST OF THE CASES
THT WE- HEARD HAVE GONE
THROUGH A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
DUE PROCESS BEFORE THEY GET TO
US WE'RE LIKE THE COURT OF
APPEALS SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
VERY DISTILLED. IN ISSUES THE
POWER. A LINE WE'RE NOT
REVIEWING THE WHOLE THING OVER
AGAIN AND SO BY THE TIME IT
GETS TO US IT'S A MUCH MORE
DISTILLED. FACT SITUATION.
OBVIOUSLY SOMEBODY NEEDS TO.
RESOLVE THOSE DISPUTES BECAUSE
THEY'RE VERY IMPORTANT TO THE
PARTIES BUT IT ALSO SHOULDN'T.
SURPRISE PEOPLE ON THE THAT
MOST OF THOSE CASES IF MOST OF
THOSE CASES GO IN FAVOR OF- OF
THE ARM. OF THE GENERAL
COUNSEL'S POSITION PURSUING A
CHARGE THAT WOULD NOT BE
UNUSUAL IT'S NOT AN UNFAIR
PROCESS IF IT'S NOT A FIFTY
FIFTY THING. IN FRONT OF OUR
BOARD ANY MORE THAN WE WOULD
THEN WE WOULD THINK THAT THAT
ON THAT A DISTRICT ATTORNEY
THAT NGUYEN YOU KNOW WHO LOSES
50% OF THEIR CASES IS DOING A
GOOD JOB OR THAT THE PROCESS IS
FAIR THAT'S PROBABLY A DISTRICT
ATTORNEY WHO'S- CHARGED CASES
THAT SHOULD HAVE NEVER BEEN
CHARGED. SO WOULD WE WOULD
EXPECT THAT THE PROSECUTION
WINS MORE CASES AND THAT
DOESN'T MAKE THE PROCESS
INHERENTLY UNFAIR IT FITS
WORKING RIGHT THAT'S HOW IT
SHOULD BE THAT DOESN'T MEAN THE
PEOPLE DON'T PUT UP A VIGOROUS
DEFENSE AND ATE A WIN BUT IF
YOU CAN'T AUTOMATICALLY DRAW A
CONCLUSION THAT THE PROCESSES
ON IS BIASED AROUND FARE- BOMB
FOR THAT REASON. AND THE AND
THAT'S THE CASE WITH US SO THAT
WAS THE POINT I WAS TRYING TO
THE IT WAS VERY GOOD BECAUSE
PERCEPTION BECOMES REALITY IN
SOME OF THESE ISSUES WE HAVE
LAWS LABOR BOARD SO I
APPRECIATED THAT. THANK YOU ALL
FOR ON YOUR PREVIOUS SERVICE
STEPPING UP FOR THE SEND OFF
CERTAINLY WHEN WE GET TO THE
I'LL HAVE THE- NEEDED TO DO BUT
TODAY LAYOFF BUT AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS FOR THE
APPOINTMENT AND I KNOW YOU'LL
SERVE THE BOARD WELL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RUNNING. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR OF. I DON'T HAVE
ANY DRAKE EITHER I WANT TO
WELCOME YOUR FAMILY AND- FOR
THEIR SUPPORT OF YOU IN THIS
ENDEAVOR AND- WE'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF KNOWING EACH OTHER
AND I'VE KNOWN YOU AS A LABOR
ADVOCATE. BUT JUST BASED ON.
HOW YOU DESCRIBE THE ROLE OF AN
APPELLATE BOARD IN THE ROLE OF
THE- OF THE- INVESTIGATIVE BODY
BLOWN IN EDUCATION AND DUE
PROCESS THAT HAPPENS- YEAR. AS
WELL TRAINED ANDPREPARED AS
ANYBODY TO SIT ON THE BOARD.
AND I ALSO PERSONALLY KNOW YOU
TO BE A PERSON OF FAIRNESS AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BOARD. NEEDS
AND REQUIRES IN IF I MIGHT-
MADAM PRO TEM I JUST RECEIVED A
LETTER TODAY. FROM THE HAS THE
LOGO'S OF THE GROWER SHIPPER
ASSOCIATION OF CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA IN THE CENTRAL LABOR
COUNCIL I'VE LIVED IN MONTEREY
COUNTY FOR FORTY YEARS. I DON'T
KNOW THAT I'VE EVER SEEN THOSE
TWO LOGO'S. SUPPORTING A
CANDIDATE FOR THE A RP OR FOR
ANY INSTITUTION TO ME THIS IS
THE STRONGEST ENDORSEMENT. THE
COULD BE SHARED IN ITS
RECOGNITION. OF YOUR ABILITY TO
BE FAIR AND TO BE RESPECTED IN
THE PROCESS AND IF ANYTHING. AS
YOU LET OFF FOR US TO ASPIRE
TOWARD ITS FOR THE ALR BE TO BE
SEEN AS FAIR AND YET FOUNDED IN
PRINCIPLES TO PROTECT WORKERS
RIGHTS RIGHTS TO ORGANIZE BUT
ALSO TO PROTECT EMPLOYERS
RIGHTS TO A CERTAIN SET OF
RULES SO. I CAN THINK OF NO
BETTER PERSON TO STEP INTO THE
STRONG AND WISH YOU ALL THE
BEST THANK YOU. THANK YOU- I
DON'T HAVE QUESTIONS I WOULD
JUST ADD TO THE FAIR- THE
FAIRNESS ISSUE STRAIGHTFORWARD
AND DIRECT IN A WAY THAT I
THINK ACTUALLY HELPS. SOLVE
PROBLEMS ARE I APPRECIATE THAT
SO MUCH. BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
REALLY NECESSARY TO BE
STRAIGHTFORWARD AND TACKLE
ISSUES LIKE THIS WITH THE KIND
OF- WELL THAT KIND OF DEMEANOR-
IT SHOWS RESPECT I THINK FOR
BOTH SIDES AND SO I JUST
THOUGHT I'D ADD THAT COMMENT. I
AS WE GO TO THE PUBLIC MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC EYE NO MORE
QUESTIONS I THINK I GOT THROUGH
EVERYONE. COMMENTS QUESTIONS-
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE APPOINTMENT YOU
CAN LINE UP AT THE MIKE AND
DIED GIVE YOUR NAME WHO YOU
REPRESENT AND VERY BRIEF
COMMENTS. THANK YOU WELCOME
GOOD AFTERNOON SHANE GUSMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS THE
AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION
MACHINISTS UNITE HERE I HAVE P.
T. LOCALS TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
UNITED- UTILITY WORKERS OF
AMERICA AND OTHERS ALL IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF MR BROAD.
PERMISSION I THINK A LOT HAS
BEEN SAID HERE THAT I. PLEASE
KEY IF SOMEONE THAT I WOULD
WITH TWO YEARS AND I CAN THINK
OF NO BETTER PERSON TO SERVE IN
THIS ROLE HE IS A PERSON OF
GREAT INTEGRITY AND- HE
DESERVES EVERYONE'S RESPECT AND
WE SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
LARA KNOWING HE CHECK ON BEHALF
OF THE GROWERS SHIPPERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF MR
BRIDES. NOMINATION I THINK
SENATOR MONNING MADE ANY POINT
I WOULD MAKE VERY WELL IT IS
ABOUT- THAT DIRECT INTERACTION
AT THAT DIVERSITY PRESERVE HAD
WITH MR BROUGHT IN THE FAIRNESS
IN THE PROCESS SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WELCOME AFTERNOON
JASON BRYANT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION WESTERNIZED DERRY'S
AND NOW WHAT COUNTY GROWERS
ALLIANCE. THAT WE'VE KNOWN VERY
FOR MANY YEARS AND ALWAYS FELT
LIKE HE WAS REALLY INTERESTED
IN UNDERSTANDING SO THE
PRESSURES AND- AND ISSUES THAT
ARE REALLY AFFECTING FARMERS ON
THE FARM. AND WE APPRECIATE ITS
RESPECTIVE WE SUPPORTERS-
APPOINTMENT AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH RICHARD. THANK YOU. HI
WELCOME. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CAITLIN VEGA FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT AND I
WANT TO JUST SAY. HE HAS BEEN A
MENTOR TO ME AND ALL OF MY
YEARS AT THE LABOR FEDERATION
AND REPRESENTING WORKERS ALSO
IN SEEING THE WAYS THAT PERRY
WAS ABLE TO WORK WITH EMPLOYERS
TO REALLY WORK WITH EVERYONE
EVERYONE WHO KNOWS HIM. I THINK
SAW THAT TO SOLVE PROBLEMS TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE THERE IS
COMMON GROUND TO REALLY
RECOGNIZE THE REALITY FOR SO
MANY WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA HOW
POWERLESS THEY ARE ON THE JOB.
AND THE NEED TO ENSURE THAT THE
GOVERNMENT- AB PROTECTS THE
MOST BASIC RIGHTS AND ENSURE
SOME LEVEL OF FAIRNESS AT THE
WORKPLACE SO HERE STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND JR
MEMBERS AS ARE THE AS ON BEHALF
OF BERRY BROADS FAN CLUB. IN
THIS VERY MUCH. WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
THERE IS A SITE WHERE WE DO
HANG MISS PERRY HAS ADVICE HIS
VOICE. HIS REASON WILL NOT SEND
A LOT OF HIS EFFECTIVENESS AND
POLICY- AND WE'RE ALSO THANKFUL
FOR THIS- BODY CONSIDERING HIM
TO APPOINT AND CONFIRM HIM- TO
THIS- OTHER BOARD THAT ALL
SHOULD BE. HE REALIZES OF SKILL
SETS ON HER FROM THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY RIVER BRIDGE OF THOSE
COMMENTS AND ON BEHALF OF THE
BUILDING TRADES WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU WELL.
NICHOLAS CHAVEZ WE HAVE HAD A
FARMWORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF MR BROUGHT FOR AGRICULTURE
LABOR RELATIONS BOARD- MR
BOBBITT'S EXPERIENCE FROM A
SERVICE OTHER STATE BOARDS AND
IS AN ATTORNEY. A COMMITMENT TO
THE END AND SENDING OF THE
SENSE OF PURPOSE OF LAW
INCLUDING THE LRA WHICH STARTS
OF THE PREAMBLE TO ENSURE PEACE
IN THE FIELD BY GUARANTEEING
TESTS FROGGER CULTURE EMPLOYEES
INSTABILITY IN THE ABERRATIONS
I TO ENSURE PEACE IN THE FIELD
BY GUARANTEEING JUSTICE FOR A
LOT OF CULTURE. PLEASE
INSTABILITY IN OUR CULTURE
LABOR RELATIONS IS WORKING
ETHIC AND LEVEL OF INTEGRITY
COMBINED WITH A SENSE OF
FAIRNESS AND DEDICATION. I'M
SORRY. IS A ETHIC WHEN LEVEL OF
AN- COMBINED WITH A SENSE OF
FAIRNESS AND DEDICATION TO
SOCIAL JUSTICE. BENEFITS ALL
PARTIES INVOLVED IN THE SPEECH
AT THE A. L. R. B. WE ARE JUST
SUPPORT. FOR THE CONFIRMATION
OF VERY BROAD. TO AGRICULTURE
LABOR RELATIONS BOARD THANK YOU
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
BECAUSE THEY'RE WALKING IN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL WORKERS
THE- C. HERE THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS
AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE
TRADE COUNCILS AS WELL. IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF MR BROTHEL
ECHO THE FOREMOST COMMENTS MADE
BY EVERYBODY ELSE AND SAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY THANK YOU
SENATOR ROTH MOUSSE MAN
SECRETARY SENATORS BATES.
MONNING MONNING AYE ROTH ALSO I
WILL CRY WILK I ATKINS SIGN A
CONCISE CONGRATULATIONS FOUR
ZERO THANK.
OKAY. MIDDLE OF THE
ROOM CLEAR A LITTLE BIT SO. OF.
SO LET ME WELCOME MISS CONNIE
GIPSON HI WHO'S BEEN APPOINTED
DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION OF
ADULT INSTITUTIONS DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION LET ME WELCOME
YOU AND THANK YOU FOR SITTING
THROUGH US SEVERAL OTHER.
APPOINTMENTS IF YOU WANT TO
INTRODUCE ANYONE THAT'S WITH
YOU YOU WOULD LIKE TO PAY
SPECIAL TRIBUTE TO AND THEN
COMMENTS QUESTIONS- WILL COME
AFTER YOU GIVE YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM PROTEOMIC COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I HAVE WITH ME TODAY MY
CDC OUR FAMILY HERE IN SUPPORT
OF I BEGAN MY CAREER IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT AS A
MEDICAL TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND PROMOTED MY WAY THROUGH THE
RANKS AND TO MY CURRENT
ASSIGNMENT IN APRIL TWENTY
NINETEEN WHY BEEN A SINGLE
PARENT RAISING TWO CHILDREN. I
CURRENTLY OVERSEE INCARCERATED
POPULATION OF APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND ADULTS AND WORKFORCE
OF OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES AS THE DIRECTOR IT IS
MY RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE WE
ARE OPERATING SAFE AND HUMANE
PRESENCE CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT
OF HEALTH FOR THOSE WHO WORK
AND LIVE WITH DAN I HAVE SEEN
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES DORN WITHIN
THIS AGENCY DURING MY TIME AT
THOSE CHANGES HAVE RESULTED AND
SAFER PRISONS ENVIRONMENT MORE
CONDUCIVE TO REHABILITATION.
ADDITIONALLY WITH THE SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE WITH THE EXPANSION
A REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING
AND A GREATER NUMBER OF LIFE
TERM OFFENDERS BEING FOUND
SUITABLE FOR PAROLE I SEE THAT
THE POPULATION HAS A NEW SENSE
OF HOPE. CDC ARE CURRENTLY NOW.
ONSITE CLASSES AT THIRTY FOUR
THIRTY FIVE OR PRESENCE. AND
OVER THELASTTWO YEARS WE'VE-
TRIPLED OUR SELF HELP PROGRAMS
AVAILABLE. THE DEPARTMENT ALSO
CONTINUES TO INVEST IN ITS
EMPLOYEES THIS INCLUDES
EXPANDING TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES TO INCLUDE AND
HAS LEADERSHIP COURSES TO
DEVELOP A COMPETENT AND DIVERSE
WORKFORCE. WHILE ALSO PROVIDING
RESOURCES FOR STAFF TO DEAL
WITH STRESS RESILIENCE. THESE
EFFORTS ARE IMPORTANT STEPS TO
WILL HELP POSITION IS
DEPARTMENT FOR FUTURE SUCCESS.
DESPITE THESE CHANGES THE
DEPARTMENT STILL FACES MANY
CHALLENGES. THE A DISRUPTION
FROM PRISON GANGS TO COP
CONTINUED INTRODUCTION OF
CONTRABAND INTO OUR PRESENCE.
AS WELL AS ENSURING THAT OUR
STAFF UNDERSTAND THEIR ROLE IN
ADVOCATING FOR THE OFFENDER'S
REHABILITATION. I WANT FOR A
STAFF TO FEEL GOOD ABOUT THE
JOB THAT THEY DO THAT THEY'RE
MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN PEOPLE'S
LIVES AND IN THE COMMUNITIES WE
SERVE. ALLOW MYSELF ALONG WITH
OTHER CITY SEE OUR EXECUTIVES
RECENTLY WENT TO NORWAY TO
OBSERVE THE CORRECTIONAL SAID
SYSTEM. AND I MUST ADMIT I CAME
BACK TRULY INSPIRED ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF CHANGE OF HOW WE
CAN CONTINUE TO IMPROVE AS I
SAW A SYSTEM THAT WAS TRULY
BASED ON HUMANITY WHAT
INSURANCE STAFF AN OFFENDER
SAFETY. I AM COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH INTERNAL AND
EXTERNAL STAKEHOLDERS TO
ADDRESS THE MANY COMPLEX
PROBLEMS AT THIS AGENCY FACES.
I AM EXCITED AND HUMBLE TO LEAD
THE DIVISION OF ADULT
INSTITUTIONS DURING THESE
TIMES. WE ARE AT THE TIME WERE
WILL CHANGE CAN OCCUR BECAUSE
AS I TALK TO STAFF MANY ARE
OPEN TO THE IDEA. THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO DO THINGS BETTER
WHICH IN THE END MAKES IT ALL.
THE BENEFITS OF SAW. IS MY
HONOR TO SERVICE THE DIRECTOR
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR MONEY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. WELCOME TRACTOR GIPSON I
ALSO WANT TO WELCOME SECRETARY
DS WHO I SEE IS IN YOUR FAN
CLUB HERE TODAY. WELCOME
SECRETARY. I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE YOU ON NOT ONLY
DISAPPOINTMENT BUT YEAR YEARS
OF SERVICE TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA- WE HAD A REALLY
GREAT CONVERSATION FROM MY
POINT OF VIEW IN TERMS OF
EDUCATING THE FOR THEIR- I KNOW
MANY IN IN THE LEGISLATURE IN
IN OUR COMMUNITY SHARE CONCERN.
AROUND THE CONTRABAND ISSUE IN
MAYBE YOU CAN YOU SHARE WITH ME
ONE PILOT PROGRAM GOING ON AND-
IF YOU COULD JUST SHARE A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENT'S APPROACH ON
CONTRABAND IN PARTICULARLY WITH
CONCERN. SOME OF THAT BROUGHT
IN BY STAFF WERE GUARDS. I'M
MORE THAN HAPPY TO SENATOR
THANK YOU CURRENTLY THE
DEPARTMENT WE RECOGNIZE WE HAVE
A CONTRABAND PROBLEM CELL
PHONES AND DRESS COMING INTO
OUR PRISONS WHICH ARE VERY
DISRUPTIVE. AND SO CURRENTLY
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN FUNDED FOR
A PILOT PROGRAM AT THE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
FACILITY WHERE WE'RE REALLY
USING A MULTI LAYERED APPROACH
TO TRY TO IN A DAY CONTRABAND.
IS INCLUDES OF CANINES WHO ARE
DOING VEHICLE SEARCHES ON.
VEHICLES WILL COME IN FOR STAFF
EMPLOYEES VISITORS VOLUNTEERS.
AS WELL AS THE USE OF AND I'LL
SAY IS. GOES INSIDE OF THE
SECURE PERIMETER IS PROCESS
THROUGH AS WELL AS THE USE OF
BAGGAGE AND PARCEL SCANNERS TO.
SCAN AND- ANYTHING THAT STAFF
OR VISITORS ARE BRINGING IT TO
THE PRESIDENT TO TRY TO
MITIGATE- CONTRABAND. WE
RECOGNIZE TO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO DO MORE AND SO WE
ARE CONTINUALLY LOOKING AROUND
FOR BEST PRACTICES LOOK AT WHAT
OTHER DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
DO. I SHARE WITH YOU SENATOR
THAT ONE OF THINGS I SAW-
HAVING TOURED ORGAN PAVILION IN
NORWAY. IS THE VERY IN DEPTH
WAY THAT STAFF RESEARCH BECAUSE
WE RECOGNIZE THAT. STAFF ARE
PART OF OUR PROBLEM AS IT
RELATES TO BRING IN CONTRABAND
UNFORTUNATELY THEY BECOME
COMPROMISED BY THE OFFENDER.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY THAT
MRS EVERYBODY SAFETY WE HAVE A
COMPROMISED EMPLOYEE. AND SO
DEPARTMENT CONTINUES EXPLORE
AVENUES AS TO HOW DO WE
CONTINUE TO ONE IDENTIFY ALL
THE POINTS OF ENTRY OF
CONTRABAND COME INTO OUR
SYSTEM. AND THEN HOW DO WE LOOK
TO MITIGATE THAT AND THEN
ELIMINATED. BECAUSE AT THE END
OF THE DAY WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
OUR PRESENCE OR SAY. THANK YOU
AND I. THINK YOU DID UNDER
SCORE THAT. AT THE CORE IS THE
SAFETY OF GUARDS AND OTHER
STAFF THEY CAN BE THE VICTIMS
OF. CONTRABAND YOU SHARE THE
PILOT PROJECT IN INTEREST I'M
GLAD THAT IT'S HAPPENING BUT-
WHAT WOULD IT TAKE FOR THAT TO
BE THE NORM AT ALL OF THE
INSTITUTIONS WHAT CURRENTLY
SERVE A PILOT PROGRAM IS UNDER
REVIEW BY- YOU CAL STATE FRESNO
IS THE RESEARCH INTO THE THAT'S
DOING THE RESEARCH ON THE-
PILOT AND WE HOPE THAT IT WILL
NOTICE A RESULT OR AT LEAST
LEADERS TO WHAT WORKS AND WHAT
DOESN'T WORK. BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT YES WE HAVE A
VERY MULTI LAYERED APPROACH AT
ONE PRESENT WE GOT THIRTY FOR
THE PRESENCE THAT ALTHOUGH ALL.
AND WHAT WE WANT TO HAVE A
SYSTEM APPROACH AND WE'VE HAD
INTERNAL MEETINGS WITHIN CITY
SEE OUR TO REALLY LOOK AT OUR
OPERATIONS AND TRY TO AS I SAID
IDENTIFIED THE AVENUES POINTS
OF ENTRY THAT THE COMMAND AND
IS. MULTIPLE WAYS UNFORTUNATELY
NOT ONLY STAFF VISITORS BUT
ALSO- BENDER PACKAGING AND I
SHARE WITH YOU SENATOR WHERE
YOU KNOW OF. OUR TEN WHO. OUR
PART OF THE GAINS ARE VERY.
THAT THEY WILL HAVE THEIR- OF
FOLKS ON THE STREET GO AND GET
EMPLOYMENT AT PLACES THAT
DELIVER TASK. AND TRY TO SHIFT
TAX SWITCH PACKAGES AND- PUT
CONTRABAND AND IT'S NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE THERE SO IS THE
ONGOING BATTLE. BUT WE ARE VERY
MUCH UP TO THE CHALLENGE OF
TRYING TO IDENTIFY ONE
RESOURCES INTO IDEALS. AND
LOOKING AT A BEST PRACTICES
NATIONWIDE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND I KNOW YOU DID REFER A
COUPLE OF TIMES TO THE-
DELEGATION YOU'RE PART OF TO
NORWAY AND YOU SHARED WITH ME
SOME OF YOUR SKEPTICISM IN THE-
NOISE A LITTLE MORE HOMOGENOUS
THAN. CALIFORNIA'S PRISON
SYSTEM. BUT YOU DID SHARE SOME
TAKEAWAYS AND MAYBE MY FINAL
QUESTION IF. WHAT WERE SOME OF
THE TAKE AWAY IS THAT YOU THINK
COULD HAVE CURRENCY IN.
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON SYSTEM
I THINK THE BIGGEST TAKEAWAY
FROM A SENATOR AS YOU SAID I
WAS A LITTLE SKEPTIC. CONAN
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
X. BACK. BUT THE REALIZATION
THAT HIT ME BY THE SECOND DAY
OF BAND THERE AND REALLY
ENGAGING WITH THE STAFF
ENGAGING WITH THEIR POPULATION.
IS NOT ABOUT THE TYPE OF
OFFENDER REALLY REALLY WANT TO
BOIL DOWN TO WAS THE
INTERACTION BETWEEN STAFF AND
THE OFFENDER. THAT AT THE END
OF THE DAY THERE WAS A MUTUAL
RESPECT THE ENGAGEMENT WITH SO
MUCH DIFFERENT. THAT IT INSURED
AND WORK TOWARD SAFETY FOR
EVERYBODY AND I THINK THAT IS.
SOMETHING THAT I TOOK AWAY
SOMETHING THAT AS A DIVISION WE
WILL BE WORKING ON. IS HOW DO
WE SWITCH OF THE DYNAMIC OF THE
ENGAGEMENT BETWEEN OUR STAFFING
THE OFFENDER WHERE IS CREATING
A MORE HUMANE ENVIRONMENT. THAT
THE END OF THE DAY ARE
INDIVIDUAL GOING HOME. AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE WE DO PRO
SOCIAL BEHAVIORS- MODIFICATIONS
THAT WERE REALLY PREPARE FOLKS
AND AT THE BEGINNING OF IT
WE'VE GOT TO BE RUN HUMANE
PRISONS. AND IT HAS TO BE. A
LEVEL PRIEST BETWEEN ARE SO IN
THE- I THINK. STAFF IN A
INTERACTION SO A KEEPING FOR ME
AND I'M EXCITED ABOUT TAKING A
CHALLENGE ON. CREATE ONE ONE
THING THAT CAME ACROSS CLEARLY
WISH YOUR ENTHUSIASM AND GIVEN
THE- AS A THE BUREAUCRACY IN
THE CHALLENGES. SOMETIMES IN
TWO YES. FALLS BY THE WAYSIDE
SO WE'RE LIKE TO HAVE KNOW. FOR
SUPPORT YEAR COME FROM. TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES. THANK YOU WE HAD A
WONDERFUL DISCUSSION IN MY
OFFICE. WITH ME IS GIVE
SENATE-TV I CONSIDER HER AN
ABSOLUTE ICON IN THE BUSINESS
OF CORRECTIONS WHAT YOU JUST
DESCRIBED IS WHAT IT ALWAYS%
GOES ON BETWEEN THE CAPTURE THE
CAPTIVE IT'S NOT A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP AND CHANGING ABOUT
PROBABLY TO SOMETHING THAT'S
CLOSER TO MENTORSHIP GASOL'S
WHERE WE WANT TO GO. SO AND I
KNOW THAT FOR THE YEARS THAT
YOU HAVE SERVICE STILL HAVE
THIS PASSION WE NEED SOME OF
YOUR JUICE MAYBE CAN SHARE THAT
WITH US BECAUSE IT'S AN AMAZING
THE AMAZING STORY BUT MY
QUESTION GOES WHICH WE DIDN'T
DISCUSS WE DISCUSSED A LOT
ABOUT RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AND
I'M I'M THERE ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT. BAD BOB THE COSTS IN
CD R. HAS GONE UP SIGNIFICANTLY
EVEN THOUGH ON THE POPULATION
IS GONE DOWN AND I'M WONDERING
IF A COMPONENT OF THAT
CERTAINLY SALARIES ON COST OF
LIVING AND NOT AS A BED IS
RESTORED AND JUSTICE FROM PAUL.
OF THE INCREASE IN CASA TYPES
OF. AND COULD YOU DO. IN TERMS
OF THAT IN THE END THE YOU KNOW
IF WE'RE GONNA HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY WE WANT TO HAVE
OUTCOMES THAT WE KNOW WE'RE
INVESTING A LOT OF MONEY AND
THAT. IS THAT THAT DOESN'T SEEM
THAT SHOULDN'T BE A NEGATIVE I
GUESS IS WHAT I'M SAYING IF YOU
CAN AKON ACCOUNT FOR THAT IN
TERMS OF THE COST OF THOSE
PROGRAMS AND HOW YOU'RE MOVING
IN THAT DIRECTION RIGHT ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I THINK IN IN
TO TALK ABOUT COST AND THE-
WHERE DOES RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
PROGRAMS PLAY INTO IT. AS I
SHARE WITH YOU SENATOR THAT
WE'VE ENGAGED IN BRAND NEW
CONTRACTS TO PROVIDE COGNITIVE
BEHAVIOR INTERVENTIONS WHICH
PART OF THAT WOULD BE VICTIM
IMPACT- CLASSES FOR OFFENDERS
AND REALLY FOCUS IN ON. THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE YOU READY
TO PEROT FIFTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS TO THE COMMUNITY TO TRY
TO ENSURE THEY GET PROGRAMMING
BUT ALSO THE DIVISION OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAM IS IN
THE PROCESS OF CONTRACTING WITH
THE UNIVERSITY TO DO JUST WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT SENATOR TO
BE ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE. THE
EFFICACY OF PROGRAMS COST
EFFECTIVE DOESN'T REDUCE
RECIDIVISM ARE WE USING AN IS
STICKING TO EVIDENCE BASED
CURRICULA WE ASSURE THAT WE
HAVE QUALIFY PROVIDERS I'M AND
I SHARE WITH YOU THAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO RAISE THE SALARIES
SO THAT WE CAN RECRUIT
QUALIFIED PROVIDERS. AND SO WE
TO KNOW WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION
TO BE RESPONSIBLE WITH THE
STATE'S MONEY AND SO THE VISION
OF REHABILITATIVE PROGRAM IS TO
PUT CONTRACTS IN PLACE TO DO
JUST WITH THAT TO REALLY LIVE
OUR PROGRAMS IS THERE EVIDENCE
BASED ARE REDUCE WE OF THEM ARE
COST EFFECTIVE. AND ARE THEY
WORKING. EIGHT YES I HAVE ANY
MORE QUESTIONS. CAN ON YOUR
NOMINATION AND YOU'LL- A- MY
ONE HUNDRED AND- PER. SUPPORT
YOU BECAUSE- FOR LEASE SENATOR
LEADING. UP JOURNEY THAT YOU
MAY ON THANK YOU FOR YOU.
SERVICE CENTER THANK YOU MISTER
VICE CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU MADAM
FOR TEN SORRY WE DID NOT GET AN
OPPORTUNITY- TO GET TOGETHER
BUT I WANT TO CONGRATULATE YOU
ON YOUR PLANET THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE- AND I APPRECIATE-
CENTER MONIES QUESTION THE
CONTRABAND. I'VE DONE MANY
TOURS OF PRISONS AND WHAT TIME
WAS THERE ON A LOCKDOWN AND I
WAS SHOCKED AT HOW MUCH
CONTRABAND- WAS THERE WHICH
OBVIOUSLY PUTS EVERYBODY AT
RISK SO THAT'S GOOD HOPEFULLY
IF IT'S SUCCESSFUL THAT WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH THAT. AND I ALSO
FEEL LIKE YOU GUYS GOT A LOT OF
MOMENTUM TO WHEN I FIRST TOWARD
WHICH IS BEFORE I GOT ELECTED
TO THE ASSEMBLY IN TWENTY
TWELVE. THERE'S NO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CLASSES. IN THE
FACILITY AT A- REAL QUICK
PEOPLE TO BE SUCCESSFUL ONCE
THEY GET OUT SO AND I KNOW
THAT'S BEEN A CRACKED YES
COOPER THAT DEAL THAT DID FULL
FUNDING A RESTORED FULL FUNDING
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES FOR DOING
THAT SO THAT'S ALL GOOD. DALY
MINISTRATION HAS SAID THAT IF.
PRISON POPULATION STAYS THE
SAME. THAT THEY PLAN TO CLOSE-
AT LEAST ONE FACILITY WITH THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS. COULD YOU
POSSIBLY SHARE WHAT THAT
CRITERIA WOULD BE. WELL I THINK
IN OCE DEPARTMENT MAKES A
DECISION IN ADMINISTRATION
DECIDES TO CLOSE THE FACILITY
THERE WILL BE SEVERAL THINGS
HAVE TO BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION WHEN CHOOSING A
FACILITY. AND IT. I'M SORRY
THERE SESSION IT. THERE ARE
SEVERAL THINGS THAT WILL BE
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION AND
ONE WILL BE THE- TWELVE PRISON
STUDY REPORT THAT HAS BEEN ONE
BY THE VENDOR THAT WILL HELP
INFORM SOME OF THAT AS IT
RELATES TO- THE COST TO REHAB
PRISONS AND WHAT HAVE YOU BUT
ALSO YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. THE
AVAILABILITY ASSESSABLE THE OF
A WORK FORCE AND THE ABILITY TO
HIRE AND RETAIN STAFF AND- TO
BE ABLE GET PROGRAM THE STAFF
AND- THE- THERE'S SEVERAL
THINGS THAT WILL BE TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT IN IS. TRYING TO ENSURE
THAT WHEN THOSE DECISIONS ARE
MADE. WHICH IS IN THE RIGHT
PRESENT. THAT WILL HOPEFULLY
HAVE THE LEAST IMPACT TO THE
STILL TRYING TO PROVIDE WHAT
OUR MISSION IS WAS
REHABILITATION TO THE OFFENDERS.
GREAT I APPRECIATE THAT ANSWER
AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING YOUR CONFIRMATION
THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU
SENATOR ROTH THANK YOU MAYOR
PRO TEM- CONGRATULATIONS MAN
AND DIRECTOR THANK YOU SIR- YOU
HAVE A VERY IMPRESSIVE RESUME.
FIVE FRANKLY LISTENED INTENTLY
TO YOUR RESPONSES AND YOUR
RESPONSES FOR EVEN MORE
IMPRESSIVE. I LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR SERVICE AND TO SING THE
PRODUCT OF YOUR EFFORTS AND- I
WILL BE MOVING IF I'M GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO YOUR
CONFIRMATION AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU FOR SERVING.
THANK YOU SENATOR- I ENJOYED
HEARING YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT-
YOUR TRIP TO NORWAY AND THE
CULTURE SHIFT. CLEARLY WE HAVE
PROBABLY GOT THE BIGGEST PRISON
POPULATION IN THE WORLD WE HAVE
A DIFFERENT CULTURE I THINK-
SENATOR MINING USE THE WORD
HOMOGENEOUS. OF FOR NORWAY
VALUE RIGHT THANK YOU THAT'S
WHAT I MEANT- SO YEAH I AND I'M
GLAD TO SEE YOUR ENTHUSIASM I
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES YOUR
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE. ARE WHAT
YOU WANT TO DO NOW THAT YOU'RE
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO STEP
INTO THIS ROLE AND BE THE ONE
TO GET TO HELP SHAPE IT. BUT
CULTURE CHANGES REALLY HARD AS
WE ARE LEARNING IN OUR OWN
HOUSE- AS IT RELATES TO THINGS
THAT WERE HAVING TO DO SO- A
YOU ARE. ON THAT LNG FLIGHT
HOME FROM NORWAY THOUGHT ABOUT
ALL THE WAYS YOU COULD. IMPRINT
UPON THIS AN IMPACTED- ID DO
YOU HAVE ANY SPECIFICS ARE
THOUGHT YOU MIGHT WANT TO SHARE
ON HOW TO GET STARTED I MEAN
YOUR VISION. IS ABSOLUTELY.
WONDERFUL YEAH I DO HAVE SOME
IDEAS SENATOR THANK YOU. I'M I
THINK THE BIGGEST THING IN AND
THIS IS A TAKE AWAY FROM
NORWAY. AND YOU DON'T THINK
ABOUT TO YOU GET OUTSIDE OF
YOUR TO ALL SYSTEM IN STAR
HEARING THESE IDEALS. BUT SOME
AS SIMPLE AS DO WE HAVE
POLICIES PROCEDURES. OR PRAY.
THAT I'LL USE THE TERM DE
ESCALATE VERSUS CLAY OR THAT
REALLY AREN'T HUMANIZING
PRACTICES THEY ARE TO THE
INFORMATION. AND I THOSE ARE
SOME THINGS THAT. QUICKLY OVER
TIME WE CAN REALLY REAL SASS
AND DECIDE BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
DOING SO FOR TWENTY YEARS IS A
STILL THE PROPER WAY TO DO
BUSINESS. WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HAVING A PRISON SYSTEM
WHERE IT IS BEHAVIOR BASS EACH
INDIVIDUAL OFFENDER IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR OWN
BEHAVIOR SHOULD BE TREATED AS
AN INDIVIDUAL NOT LOVE TO SOME
LUCK TOGETHER IN THIS. GROUP
AND WE SAY THESE ARE CARE
POLICIES THAT WE'VE HAD IN
PLACE FOR TWENTY YEARS JUST
APPLY AS A ONE OF THE BIGGEST
THINGS THAT I HAVE A WORK GROUP
NOW SENATOR THAT'S WORKING ON
THIS. THE FIRST ONE WE'RE
TACKLING AS AND NOW USES SHOULD
EVERY OFFENDER IN RESTRICTIVE
HOUSING AND RESTRICTIVE HOUSING
IS WHERE AN OFFENDER MAY GO
BECAUSE THEY HAVE SAFETY
CONCERNS- THAT HAVEN'T. BEEN
RESOLVED THAT THEY'VE GOT A
DISCIPLINARY. BUT DOES A
OFFENDER AND RESEARCH TO
HOUSING HAS TO BE IN RESTRAINTS
ALL THE TIME IS THAT REALLY
NEED IT AND SO IT SEEMS LIKE
THAT THAT I THINK WE CAN DO A
CRITICAL ASSESSMENT OF OUR OWN
POLICIES PRACTICES. AND
PROCEDURES AND THAT'S A
STARTING POINT THE OTHER PART
THAT I THINK IS CRITICAL. AND
I'M VERY APPRECIATIVE
ADMINISTRATION IN THIS S THAT
OUR TRAINING OUR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FROM R. A C. POST AS
WELL AS OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OVER TRAINING ACADEMY ARE GOING
TO NORMAL MARCH. AND I REALLY
WANT THEM TO LOOK AT. SOME OF
THEIR TRAINING IN HOW THEY
TRAIN BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S
THINGS THAT WE CAN DO-
DIFFERENTLY. AND THE AND THE
BIG KEY PART OF IT FOR ME IS
REALLY. RESHAPING REDEFINING.
THE STAFF IN MADE IN OUR
ACTIONS WE'VE GOT IT WE TO
FLYING THAT. AND MAKE IT OKAY
FOR US AFTER YOU KNOW I GO OUT
SENATOR AND I HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO. BRAND
NEW CADETS ON DAY TWO OF THEIR
THIRTEEN WEEK ACADEMY. AND I
TALK TO THEM ABOUT THEIR
WORLDLY REHABILITATION. IS
REALLY ABOUT MODELING PROSOCIAL
BEHAVIORS AN ADVOCATE BUT THEY
HAVE BEEN THERE IN THEIR
REHABILITATION BECAUSE THEY'RE
COMING HOME. BUT PART OF THAT
MEANS YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH FOLKS. AND I
THINK SOMETIMES WE'VE. ALMOST
PUT UP A BARRIER WHEN OUR STAFF
IN REGARDS TO BE TALKED ABOUT
YOU DON'T WANT TO BE.
COMPROMISE YOU DON'T WANT TO
BE. CAUGHT UP BY THE OFFENDER
FORCES WE NEED TO SAY I NEED TO
BE PERSONABLE I NEED TO SAY HI
GOOD MORNING TO FOLKS HOW WAS
IT I HEARD THAT YOUR SON
GRADUATED BICYCLE HOW DID THAT
GO. VERSUS PRIVATE I DON'T NEED
TO TELL THE OFFENDER WHAT YOU
DID LAST NIGHT. AND I THINK
THAT'S GOING TO BE A RE
EDUCATION OF OUR SYSTEM. TO GET
PEOPLE TO THINK A LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY BUT I THINK IT CAN
BE DONE I TRULY THINK. WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT HEALTH OF AN
INSTITUTION EMPLOYEES AND THE
OFFENDERS THE DYNAMIC OF FOLKS
WHO WERE THERE TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN WITH EACH OTHER HAS TO BE
IMPROVED AND HAS TO BE
DIFFERENTLY AND I KNOW IT'S A
HUGE HUGE ON TAKING I'M NOT
NAIVE IN THIS. BUT MY INTENT IS
REALLY TO START TO GROW MORE.
TO AFFECT CHANGE AND THAT'S
WHAT I WANTED TO SENATOR. THANK
YOU I WILL LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING MORE ABOUT HOW THIS IS
GOING AS I LOOK AT THE
SECRETARY- IN AND TO ENSURE THE
SUPPORT IS THERE- SO THAT YOU
DON'T LOSE THAT ENTHUSIASM
BECAUSE I KNOW IT'S HARD WORK.
I DON'T THINK ANY OF US HAVE
THE AT AN IDEA OF JUST HOW HARD
IT IS FRANKLY- SO THANK YOU AND
CONGRATULATIONS WITH THAT LET
ME- SEE IF THERE ARE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HERE IN SUPPORT. IF
YOU WANT TO COME UP TO THE MIKE
I WILL ASK FOR YOUR NAME WHO
YOU'RE REPRESENTING AND A BRIEF
OPPOSITION. THANKTHANK YOU
MADAM COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME'S ORGANS ALL THE STATE
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL SUPERVISORS
ORGANIZATION I REPRESENT FIVE
THOUSAND SUPERVISORS AND
MANAGERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
ARE VARIOUS PRISONS. I
PERSONALLY HAVE BEEN AND
FORTUNATE TO WORK WITH CONNIE
ON VARIOUS PROJECTS TO MY C. C.
R. CAREER. AND ON BEHALF OF THE
ORGANIZATION OF MYSELF WE
SUPPORT THE POSITION OF
DIRECTOR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME WELCOME AND THANK YOU.
I'M WITHIN SAM BROWN SAID I
WORK AT SANGUINE STATE PRISON I
AM THE STATE SECRETARY OF SIXTY
SO AND JUST LIKE THE STATE
PRESIDENT SAID WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF COUNTY GIPSON FOR
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA PART
OF CORRECTIONS I'LL TELL YOU
THIS IN MY IN MY TIME IN THE
PART OF CORRECTIONS- I THINK
YOU KNOW PEOPLE YOU HEAR ABOUT
PEOPLE'S NAMES A NO ABOUT FROM
FROM THEIR REPUTATIONS- YOU
KNOW GOOD THINGS ABOUT PEOPLE
FROM THEIR REPUTATIONS. AND
BEFORE I PUT A FACE TO THE
PERSON- I HAD I KNOW- I KNEW OF
COUNTY GIPSON. AND SHE'S BEEN.
A STALWART IN THE- AT THAT IT
HAS MOVING FORWARD SO WE AREN'T
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HI WELCOME HELLO. MATTHEW
MCVEIGH UNLESS STATE TREASURER
FOR CCS SO. I'M A SOCIAL MORE
NICK KERN VALLEY STATE PRISON.
AND I JUST WANT TO ECHO THE
THOUGHTS OF MY PEERS AND- WERE
IN SUPPORT OF COUNTY GIPSON.
THANK YOU. HI WELCOME AFTERNOON
THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS VANESSA
MELENDEZ I AM A CORRECTIONAL
SERGEANT I'M CURRENTLY ASSIGNED
TO THE BACKGROUND UNITS SO I'M
AND- ESSENTIALLY IN CHARGE OF
SOME OF THE HIGHER AND- I'VE
MET MISS GIPSON A FEW TIMES AND
SHE'S A PHENOMENAL- MENTOR
SHE'S AN INCREDIBLE INDIVIDUAL
SHE'S ALWAYS POSITIVE. AND
SHE'S ALWAYS ENCOURAGING- I
THINK HER FOR A PAVING THE WAY
FOR WOMEN LIKE ME STILL FAIRLY
NEW TO THE DEPARTMENT- AND
SHE'S I CAN'T SAY ENOUGH GOOD
THINGS ABOUT HER BUT SHE'S
DEFINITELY A PILLAR TO THIS
DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU FOR.
THANK YOU HI. HEY GOOD LUCK
HIGH AND THAT. RATE GOES US.
CORRECTION SERGEANT YOU SEE
THAT HAVE HERE AND OF COUNTY
GIVE. AND THE SAME THING AS
EVERYONE. REPORTER THANK YOU.
HI WELCOME GOING TO STATE
PRESIDENTS CPO WE REPRESENT
TWENTY SO HOURS MEN AND WOMEN
AND CORRECTION AND WHO FOR BAHA
COLONY ENJOY WITH INITIALLY
GREAT JOB THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OKAY I ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY SENATOR ROTH OKAY MADAM
SECRETARY CENTERS BATES.
MONNING AYE MONNING AYE ROTH
ROTH AYE WILK NINE WILK AYE
ATKINS HI ATKINS SIGN BATES AYE
BATES AYE. YEAH CHRIS. WE'LL
SAVE THAT CONVERSATION TO GIVE
YOU A HARD TIME LATER-
CONGRATULATIONS IT WAS
UNANIMOUS. THANK YOU ALL FOR
JOINING HER TODAY. OKAY I THINK.
I NEED TO SEE WHERE WE ARE. YOU
KNOW SPACES LEFT. IT GIVE IT A
MOMENT FOR PEOPLE TO EXIT AND
WILL GO INTO EXECUTIVE SESSION.
WE'LL TAKE WE'LL TAKE A FIVE
MINUTE BREAK SO THAT PEOPLE CAN.
TAKE A BREAK.